Herr Söder ja die erste Frage an Sie wir
haben uns eben kurz vor der Sendung
unterhalten sie sagten sie hätten Robert
habe gestern hier im Interview gesehen
der davon sprach dass der Kern der
deutschen Wirtschaft auf dem Spiel stehe
wie würden sie die Situation umschreiben
ja ich glaube schon dass wir in einer
veritablen Staatskrise sind in einer
dauerhaften Wirtschaftskrise ohnehin es
fällt ja auf dass um uns herum die
Wirtschaft trotz der internationalen
Rahmenbedingungen eher wächst
Deutschland geht zurück und sofern haben
wir jetzt zwei echte Probleme das eine
ist dass eine Regierung de facto
handandlungsunfähig ist meiner nach
selbstverschuldet durch eben das Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgericht und zum
anderen dass wir keine echte
Wirtschaftsstrategie haben damit
umzugehen und überhaupt keine
Energiestrategie wie wir die Industrie
und den Mittelstand in Deutschland
stärken und das beides zusammen führt zu
tiefer Verunsicherung und wenn man es
mal so vergleichen soll im Moment
scheint nicht so richtig in Deutschland
zu gehen die Regierung trifft nichts und
im Fußball ist es ganz genauso beides eh
trostlose
Perspektive das Gefühl vielleicht frage
ich erst Robin Alexander Alexander das
Gefühl dass man auch hat ist da gibt es
schon und ich habe Robert habe gestern
danach gefragt zu ein gewisses frolocken
so hätte es glaube ich ausgedrückt eine
Art Schadenfreude auch auf Seiten der
Opposition dass das jetzt so schief
gegangen ist sehen Sie das auch so nee
das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so also ich
fand Herr Söder hat ja gerade auch nicht
schadenfrohe nein nein nein nein ich hab
nicht ih gemeint aber
da muss man auch wirklich sagen
die CDU die geklagt hat die Union hat es
den ja vorher gesagt also ich erinnere
mich an diese parlamentsreden der der
ABG ma Middelberg für die Union hat so
erklärt äh und es ist so gekommen wie
die Opposition gesagt hat und dann in
von habbeeg in diesem ersten Impuls am
Montag zu sagen wer jetzt ein Problem
kriegt der kann Brief an Friedrich MZ
Schreiben der ist schon das geht nicht
weil das und interessanterweise ist hat
das habck schon einmal getan und es
reißt ein ich erinnere mich als diese
LNG Terminals gebaut wurden da klagte
die Deutsche Umwelthilfe ob das rechtens
ist und bin ich gar kein Anhänger der
Umwelthilfe und ich bin auch gar nicht
gegen LNG Terminals aber hab gesagt den
das könnt ihr doch nicht machen wenn ihr
mit der Klage durchkommt so und das geht
nicht also das weil das Recht muss schon
vor der als gut empfundenen Politik
stehen und dass ihm das jetzt wieder
passiert ist ich glaube im im Zorn das
ist nicht gut ich das ist interessant
und das wirkt sehr unbeherrscht und es
wirkt vor allem ohne einenerkennbaren
Plan die Reaktionen von der
Bundesregierung sind ja davon getragen
dass sie im Grunde n nicht wissen was
sie tun sollen und wenn man noch mal
zurückgeht wir haben ja damals als
Länder jetzt den dem Bund geraten in so
Situation in der man sein kann also man
kann schon begründen dass die Gesamtlage
sich deutlich verändert hat das war noch
die Auswirkungen von Corona war noch
nicht vorbei es war auch die
Herausforderung wie geht's weiter mit
anderen Dingen auch letztes Jahr die
große Krise mit Ukraine Umstellung der
Energie da kann man die Notlage in der
eine Notsituation in der in der
Schuldenbremse die es nämlich gibt
begründen aber Christian Lindner V allem
war bockbeinig und zum Teil auch bin
ehrlich ein bisschen überheblich und hat
damals gesagt nein ich mache das alles
wir haben gesagt du erfüllst die
Schuldenbremse so wie du sie sagst nur
indem du trickst und das war dann halt
der Vorschlag der gemacht wde wir hätten
ich hätte das mitgetragen ich hätte das
damals mitgetragen weil ich da fest
überzeugen war Ausnahmesituationen
erfordern auch vernünftiges umgehen mit
so einer Situation und zwar weder
triumphfgeheul nach noch taktische
Spielchen da steht die Wirtschaft auf
dem Spiel da stehen Arbeitsplätze auf
dem Spiel da steht dauerhafter Wohlstand
auf dem Spiel aber die Ampel wollte
nicht muss man sagen und hat ja damals
nicht oder wer wollte es nicht sie haben
es gerade klar ich hab es gestern
versuchtr lindner war war damals schon
sehr
sehr selbstbewusst im Auftreten ich
verstehe auch man sieht jetzt auch die
aktuelle Situation in der FDP die die
Ampel zusätzlich belastet mit der
möglichen Mitglieder Entscheid jetzt hab
jetzt vor einigen Stunden gelesen ginder
wollte die Schuldenbremse erhalten
formal obwohl man klar war das ist eine
Art von trickerrei war und das haben wir
als falsch empfunden das haben wir ihm
auch gesagt und dann kam ja noch dazu
dass die Umwidmung auf die Klimamittel
nun gar nichts mit Corona zu tun hat man
hätte ja noch argumentieren können na ja
Corona und krieg das ist so eine so eine
Sondersituation aber die langfristige
klimaherausforderung war denkbar klar
nicht damit vereinbar aber es war der
Wunsch und die haben das durchgezogen
und deswegen kann man den Vorwurf nicht
an die machen die die sozusagen das
Recht hergestellt haben und jetzt bin
ich gespannt was die Ampel macht im
Moment sehe ich kaum einen Vorschlag
kaum eine Idee wie sie die Situation
lösen können das muss man vielleicht
Robin Alexander einmal noch mal kurz
erklären ja weil mir das vorher also vor
der Beschäftigung auch nicht so klar war
wie wie wirklichen Profis wie Ihnen also
wenn man solche sonderhaushalte auflegen
will ähm dann muss man das gut begründen
es gibt im deutschen Grundgesetz diese
Schuldenbremse die besagt das geht so
nicht kann es nicht einfach sozusagen
ins unendlich hinein Kredite aufleben
und auf pumpleben interessanterweise
sagte gestern jemand die diese
Schuldenbremse erdacht und Sonnen von
drei
politpensionären die wussten wenn das
irgendwann mal akut wird haben Sie
wahrscheinlich alle mit aktiver Politik
nichts mehr zu tun wä ich biss skeptisch
weilb nicht
schwe auch eine Schuldenbremse Koch per
Steinbrück und Tor Seehofer ne ja aber
die Schweiz hat auch eine Schuldenbremse
und schon länger und das ist die Welt
auch nicht untergegangen also vor allem
sie sie bietet ja entschuldigen Sie sie
bietet ja Möglichkeiten auf solche
schwierigigen Situation zu gehen also
Schuldenbremse gibt's ja schon länger
auchau in den Ländern später scharf
gestellt als im Bund und wir haben
während der coronazeit auch ganz bewusst
sie aussetzen können um die Wirtschaft
zu retten um durch Corona zu kommen es
hat funktioniert und natürlich in
solchen außergewöhnlichen Jahren kann
das doch jeder begründen aber man wollte
ganz bewusst nicht es tun und deswegen
ähm trifft auch die Schuld dieamp wobei
ich auch sagen muss ich habe da kein
triumphgol das ist für Deutschland ein
solcher Schaden wenn wir eine Regierung
haben die nicht mehr handlungsfähig ist
ähm ähm und man fragt ja auch was ist
jetzt die Lösung am letzten Wochenende
hieß es noch wir setzen auf jeden Fall
den Haushalt die Woche durch jetzt ist
alles abgesagt und ich rate dringend
dazu ich rate dringend der Ampel dazu
auch dem bundeskannst jetzt mal eine
Regierungserklärung zu geben dieses
dauerhafte Schweigen dieses dauerhafte
im Grunde ommen entweder den Eindruck zu
vermitteln ich weiß es nicht oder was er
manchmal tut ich sage es euch nicht äh
macht eine dermaßen große Unsicherheit
und deswegen dringende Empfehlung rasch
klare Konzepte zu haben entweder eine
Art von Notlage erneut zu schaffen das
müssten sie verantworten oder
Einsparpläne vorzulegen es gibt eine
Reihe von Möglichkeiten dazu ob es vom
Volumen her ganz geht das wird sich
zeigen aber die Ampel muss jetzt ihren
Job tun sie hat sich in den letzten
Wochen einfach entschieden mit der Union
zwar mal Kaffee trinken zu gehen aber de
facto den Deutschland Fakt auszusetzen
also geht keine andere Chance hab ich
sie falsch verstanden dass sie sagen im
Grunde ist diese Regierung die hat
fertig mal einen berühmten
Fußballtrainer zu zitieren die kann
einpacken na da mussand zurücktreten na
ja also soll ich jetzt sagen ein
einzelner Rücktritt löst ja das Problem
nicht man ist ja das ich habe heute
irgendwo gelesen in einem Kommentar noch
mal über den Fußball man ist gar nicht
mehr sauer man hat da Mitleid mit den
mit mit der deutschen Nationalmannschaft
jetzt habe ich kein Mitleid mit der
Ampel aber ich mache mir echt Sorgen
deswegen sage ich auch Staatskrise weil
am Ende das habt wir im letzten Jahr
auch gesehen bei heizgesetz ich habe das
ja im wkampf auch erlebt es gewinnt
nicht automatisch die Opposition die
führende Kraft sondern alle die sagen
dieser Staat funktioniert nicht der
Staat muss weg wir brauchen anderen
Staat der große afdspruch Reset der mal
genannt wird der kriegt natürlich
weiteren auf die AFD muss ja gar nichts
machen und deswegen ist wichtig schnell
und klar ein Handlungskonzept vorzulegen
ob es die Ampel noch kann ich meine das
ist jetzt die bewerrungs wür sie sagen
MS müssen zurücktreten also ich weiß
noch nicht wie sie es weitermachen soll
das mussen sie selber entscheiden äh
gibt auch Leute die sagen Neuwahlen in
der jetztetzigen Situation wäre eine
denkbare Variante ist auch schwierig
auch schwierig na wenn die keine
Regierung zustande Brechten wenn jetzt
die FDP ausscheidet es gibt keine
Regierung die zustande kommt ich habe
vor Wochen schon gesagt bin ich
gescholten waren
oh ich gesagt also mit FDP und grün
wird's nicht gehen die Fliehkräfte sind
so groß ich halte sie nicht für
regierungsfähig Scholz soll quasi die
Partner die er jetzt hat entlassen wir
stünden bereit um in der Notsituation
vielleicht Verantwortung zu übernehmen
wurde alles abgelehnt die Union wäre es
dann natürlich sie auch ja nicht nicht
Person in der Bundesregierung da W
Friedrich Matz die klare Nummer ein aber
beische ministerent leistet der pers ein
beitragin alander noch noch einmal um
das kurz zu erklären man müsste
sozusagen Herr Söder hat gerade erklärt
die Notlage erklären dann wäre das kein
Problem mit diesem vielen Geld
gewesen Problem ist natürlich jetzt man
kann eine Notlage im letzten Jahr
aufgrund der Situation erklären aber
jetzt eine Notlage zu erklären wegen dem
Urteil ist natürlich auch schwierig
obwohl das Verfassungsgericht den den
Regierungen in solchen Situation eine
einen großen SP toal interessanter Punkt
ich hab gestern mit mit Stefan weil dem
niedersächsischen Ministerpräsidenten
nach der Sendung noch kurz mich drüber
unterhalten und der sagte auch Jurist
der sagte dieses Wort Notlage lässt sehr
vielen Spielraum in so einem
Gesetzestext das kann man sehr weit
fassen und
ähm meinte man könnte dann tatsächlich
begründen dieses Urteil bringt uns jetzt
in eine Notlage wir erklären das zur
Notlage und dann können wir tun was wir
eigentlich tun wollen also die
Diskussion in der Bundesregierung ist da
noch im Fluss mm deshalb bin ich jetzt
vorsichtig aber stand heute gehen dern
interne Debatten dahin dass sie
tatsächlich eine Notlage erklären aber
darauf abheben dass das die durch den
russische Invasion verursachten
Energiepreise wären und die verwerf
und dass man damals ja die die
Konstruktion die jetzt baden gegangen
ist gewählt hatte um um die Notlage
herumzukommen und wenn die Konstruktion
nicht ginge wäre die Notlage ja da ob
das dann vor Gericht hält weiß ich nicht
aber es ist ja tatsächlich eine Notlage
da also es hat eine innere
faktenwahrheit also ich will auch nicht
jetzt ich persönlich sage mal auch nicht
mein Ziel jetzt eine Regierung einfach
zu zerdümmern um ein Vorteil davon zu
haben das machen die schon leider selbst
muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen sagen aber
wir haben Interesse auch staatspolitisch
dass dieses Land funktioniert also wenn
man die beiden vs mal nimmt der eine V
der jetzt angegriffen wurde die 60
Milliarden ja der ist nicht das ke
Problem weil das ist eh profoturo also
für die Zukunft gerichtet und ich würde
auch wirklich sagen also von
Einsparmöglichkeiten gbes Dingen dieses
unsähige heizungsgesetz aus meiner Sicht
dieses aus schlecht verantwortte
Bürgergeld ich finde es übrigens auch
ein gutes Signal des Bundeskanzlers wenn
in so einer Zeit einfach mal diesen
Umbau des Kanzleramtes für eine
Milliarde geplant einfach lässt wer z.B
mal Symbol klar löst das
Haushaltsproblem nicht aber den
deutschen zu signalisieren ich nehme von
meinen brunkpaläen Abstand Schluss damit
das mache ich nicht ich setze ein Signal
an meine an meine Koalition so für die
anderen Fragen die jetzt ausgezahlten
energiegelder also da wä es natürlich
ein schwerer schind die 200 Milliarden
ne das ist der wenn man da jetzt her
gehen würde und sagen würde man und das
ist auch richtig der vor ist genauso
wohl verfassungsmig genau gegen den ist
aber noch nicht geklagt worden tun man
müs muss logischer kononsen wird jetzt
gerade geprüft ob das gemachtür das tun
ich rate der Bundesregierung es alles
auf ein auf Sam die jetzt von sich aus
wieder ein ja das können Sie den machen
da ist tatsächlich eine gute
Argumentation da allerdings würde ich
auch
dringendraten parallel dazu die
Energiepolitik generell auf andere Füße
zu stellen denn die Höhe der Preise bei
uns ergibt sich ja nicht nur aufgrund
der Tatsache dass wir umstellen müssen
sondern dass wir uns selbst betrügen
schauen Sie wir Zehen Kernenergie teuer
aus Frankreich weil wir selber nicht
wollen wir beziehen extrem teures
Flüssiggas und freacking Gas aus den USA
weil wir selber nicht machen ich
empfehle und fordere quasi dass wir
neben dem jetzt irgendwie lösen dieser
jetzigen Geschichte auch die
Energiepolitik auf ökonomisch
vernünftige Beine stellen mit einem Plan
für Kernenergie und auch für freakingas
um einfach die hohe der Energiepreise
die Höhe dauerhaft zu se okay aber was
ist dann die Forderung her das die
Forderung Tracking in in in in
Deutschland na schauen sie ja natürlich
aber schau es ist do Niedersachsen da da
W geht
total ist wohl nichts da schade ja hätte
auch Vorteile ja aber schau das ist doch
total unmoralisch jetzt mal gerade an
die Grünen die sind der Haupt Gegner ist
do total unmoralisch wo anders das zu
machen zu beziehen für vieles Geld zu
importieren und selber nicht zu leisten
da dar ist übrigens auch die
grundlegende Schwäche der deutschen
Energiepolitik das ist aber nichts für
den Moment schon klar aber den Brauch
auch eine Konzeption für den
wirtschaftsstandard
aleres maliztiös ist glaube ich das
richtige Wort ich geguckt auch
entschuldigung ich habe interessiert
geguckt weil das stimmt alles aber es
gehört zur Wahrheit dass nicht nur die
Grünen alles immer verhindert haben
sondern auch Ministerpräsidenten auch
unionsministerpräsidenten also
beispielsweise die Abscheidung von
Kohlenstoff der entsteht da waren
unionsministerpräsidenten dagegen die
Abscheidung ne die
absreibung hatte die Merkel fertig und
dann angfen und damit kann ich doch
nicht in die kommunalwah also also dies
dieses wir steigen aus allem aus und
nirgendwo ein ist kein exklusives grünes
Problem es ist auch ein grünes Problem
aber paar andere haben da richtig
mitgehangen und wenn man sich anguckt
stromleitungsbau Trassenbau dann haben
auch welche mit drin gehangen die hier
in der Runde Sitz und ich habe sogar
rubertber überzeugt dass wir eine
weitere Stromleitung nach Bayern machen
haben Sie das gemacht Herr Söder der ja
morgen bei uns ich bin überzeugend
ich hab überzeugt wie haben Sie das
gemacht mit roher Gewalt oder nein nein
nein mit Argument Realität ich meine wir
sind in anderen Lage als noch vor d vi
Jahren ja aber aber Hubert eiwanger hat
2020 gesagt diese Trassen geht gar nicht
also auf gar keinen Fall 2022 sagt er
dann das sehr interessant na ja also
eine wenn die da ist ist besser als wenn
sie nicht da ist was auch immer das
heißen soll jetzt fordert derselbe
Hubert eiwanger eine dritte Trasse da
sehen sie mal dass meine Argumente zwar
ein bisschen Zeit brauchen aber
wirken se flexibel nein ich war nicht
dagen wurde immer behauptet Seehofer war
immer dagegen auch der Seehofer war für
die Erdverkabelung und das wiederum für
die Verkabelung das hat übrigens jetzt
auch dazu geführt dass es weniger Klagen
dagegen gibt das hat schon Vorteil auch
wenn es zu lange gedauert hat wobei
heute die Probleme nicht die großen
Leitungen sind sondern durch die vielen
Energie Anlagen die man machen wird die
kleinen um das zuzuliefern aber mal das
das alles hat Alexander völlig recht es
nützt uns im Moment nichts ich mache
auch den Grünen keinen Vorwurf dass sie
vor 10 Jahren der gegen waren sondern
ich mache jetzt die Aufforderung jetzt
eine Lösung zu finden und einfach der
Realität ins Auge zu schauen diese diese
Schattenhaushalte diese Trickserei ne
was anderes das Wort Luft Luftbuchungen
lese ich auch immer wieder das haben ja
auch mehrere Länder ne das hat ja auch
Günther in Schleswig-Holstein hat das
Thema auch wüst in
nordrin-westfalen Herr Wegner in Berlin
hat das Thema auch
Stefan B sagte gestern auf Nachfrage wir
sind sauber in Niedersachsen das weiß
ich nicht ja natürlich aber wir haben
uns auch überlegt wir haben uns damals
genau überlegt ist es eine Option weil
wenn der Bund quasi normal ist ja so ne
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremsen bei Corona
war vorgabe durch den Bund und haben es
die Länder angewandt hab gesagt ist das
ein Konzept unser Finanzminister war
strickt dagegen wir hatten es rechtlich
mal alles geprüft haben unseren Haushalt
dann alles mit unseren Geldern bezahlt
gebe ich auch zu weil wir so ein
bisschen leichter haben weil wir
erfolgreich flüssig sind ja wenn man den
ein länderfanzausgleich zahlen würden
dann richtig aber es ging wir haben
alles g Liquid natural Geld unser
Finanzminister hat es damals sehr
bockbeinig da waren einige im Kabinett
sauer es hat er gut gemacht und bin ja
auch heute dankbar dafür dem Albert
fürger dass es gemacht hat wir sind da
sauber müssen NS zurück sein sehen sie
auch so Herr
Alexander mir ist aufgefallen dass Herr
Söder in den letzten Tagen nach diesem
Urteil gar nicht so laut war und deshalb
glaube ich werden sich das Leute in
Bayern noch mal angucken und ja klar da
gibt's auch eine Klage da G aber das
sind wir aber ich war nicht laut ich war
nicht laut weil ich nicht über noch mal
ich
bin also ich habe ich habe eine Sorge
dass ein Großteil der
Menschen ich habe ein Wahlkampf hinter
mir wo ich das alles erlebt habe AFD
hautner wir haben jetzt eine neue AFD
Fraktion Rotz
freche Typen und anders tut mir leid
wenn ich das so sagen muss und
irgendwelche Jungen die mit Hitlergruß
aufgefallen sind die schon mal ein Tag
in urhaft waren und so ich habe vor
denen keine Angst ja ich habe mich ich
glaube die auch kann man kann man
demokratisch überzeugt besiegen nur wenn
dann solche Fehler passieren weim ist
nicht gescheitert an den zu starken
Nazis sondern zu schwachen Demokraten
verstehen sie und das macht mir Sorge
ich habe das erlebt wie das ausufert und
deswegen mir ist lieber dass wir am Ende
für die Wirtschaft eine Stabilität
bekommen und das was jetzt ist es stürzt
das ganze Land in Unsicherheit das noch
mal war nicht das Thema gerade ne das
Thema war die Schattenhaushalte na ich
bin ja beruflich an Berlin gebunden und
kann mit den bayerischen landeshar nicht
angucken aber selbst ich habe
mitbekommen dass es bei ihnen mal eine
Debatte gab dass sie Corona Milliarden
aufgenommen men haben und dann ihre
Hightech Initiative davon bezahlt haben
und jetzt im Lichte dieses Urteils ist
das nicht was ähnliches nee also es gab
die Überlegung es ist altes
Haushaltsrecht gewesen W Corona es gab
die Überlegung ob man das so machen kann
oder nicht wir haben am Ende dann alles
bezahlt mit dem mit dem reellen Geld aus
dem Haushalt also wir hatten es überlegt
weil der Bund es eben in anführungsst
vorgemacht hat es gab die Überlegung und
dann haben wir hat der Finanzminister
gesagt er macht das Ganze nicht er macht
es anders insofern war das vielleicht
Glück oder oder gute Willen aber unsere
finanzmister sie hatten 20 Milliarden
coronakredite und da war noch 5
Milliarden übrig und die haben wir eben
dann nicht gezogen die haben wir nicht
gezogen haben nicht übertragen der
Vorwurf kam ja an die Bundesregierung
des übertrags genau quasi ins nächste
Jahr und dann noch die Umwidmung in
anderses Ziel das war die vor aber sie
haben es vorbereitet wir haben wir haben
wir haben es natürlich überlegt und
haben es vorbereitet haben sie
nicht die kreditfinanzierten Maßnahmen
müssen einen sachlichen und zeitlichen
Zusammenhang mit der notl haben im
Hinblick auf das Haushaltsgesetz 22 ist
aus Sicht des rechnungshrufes der
erforderliche enge sachliche
Zusammenhang grundsätzlich
fraglich stimmen sie zu welche
Rechnungshof Rechnungshof welcher könnte
das gewesen sein der Rechnungshöfe sind
im ganzen Land gibt's ganz viele ihr
eigener war das gibt sogar beim CDF
einhof ja ich war ihr eigener ja ja
deswegen haben wir
Drohung war keine Drohung das schonst
zweiter zweiter Satz der Rechnungshof
sieht das Risiko dass insbesondere
notlagebedingte Kreditermächtigungen so
nennt man das ja für Zeiten das genau
der Knackpunkt bis weit nach der
Pandemie vorrätig gehalten werden mus so
sagen Geld auf Vorrat anhä gen genau das
haben wir dann angenommen genau diese
Empfehlung haben wir angenommen okay das
aber das war der Plan das wollten sie
machen nein wir wir haben es uns
überlegt gehabt weil der Bund es so
gemacht hat aber wir hatten einfach
grundlegende bedenken das zu tun haben s
nicht gemacht wann haben Sie das
abgeräumt weiß ich nicht meh ganz genau
rechtzeitig weil passiert alles rechts
zeitigil so zumindest nicht so
rechtzeitig dass nicht z.B glaub die
Kollegen der süddeutschen und andere
auch davon Wind bekommen haben es wurde
ja mehrfach gerügt und auch und auch
besprochen ja aber ich habe z nichts
gelesen was da irgendwie negativ war die
Sache ist die Sache ist in trocken
Tüchern bei uns
mhm
diese Greif aber übrigens auch nicht die
anderen an weil die anderen Länder waren
ja in der viel schlechteren Lage also
wir haben damals noch das man noch mal
noch mal rekapituliert ich habe damals
auch für die Länder die wirklich an der
Krücke gegangen sind
habe ich damals gesagt Mensch erklärt
doch mal da hat damals ein bisschen auch
Diskussion mit Friedrich gegeben be
Friedrich Matz war auch für die ganz
klare Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse ganz
taff ich habe damals gesagt weil
einzelne Länder Probleme haben es macht
noch mal den Sinn das zu verlängern um
sozusagen in der schweren Zeit
Stabilität zu haben da war ich habe ich
da sehr angegriffen Christian Lindner
sowieso ich habe das übrigens selbst vor
vor der Bundestagswahl 2021 mal gesagt
da war so eine große elefantenrun den
ARD und CDF hat Christian Linden gesagt
mit ihmals Finanzminister wird es
niemals je irgendwieder eine Veränderung
geben ich habe ihm damals schon gesagt
überlegt du das genau was du tust weil
außer Ereignisse können dann dazu
zwingen und eins darfen man nicht
vergessen die Amerikaner die uns
wirtschaftlich echt herausfordern erneut
mhm freundschaftlich verbunden
finanzieren ihre gesamten
abwerbeversuche zum einen mit teurem
freackingas aber vor allem auch mit
großen Schulden das heißt Schulden sind
per se ja nicht was schlimmes sie sind
dann schlimm wenn sie verwendet werden
für sogenannte konsumtive Ausgaben wenn
sie verwendet werden für Investitionen
für Deutschland in Hightech straßenba da
wäre es ja gar nicht so schlimm die
Schuldenbremse hat man damals gemacht um
zu verhindern dass ich Haushalte
komplett überschulden und dann wegen
Zinslast zusammenbrechen siee Europa
siee damals griechis Beispiel und dann
hat man das so eingebaut es war die
Empfehlung in einer schweren
Notsituation kann man mal muss man
vielleicht auch siee Corona muss man
solche Entscheidungen treffen und es gab
diese so selbstverschuete bisschen ganz
war das gerade am Anfang der Ampel die
das nicht wollte mm wei sachlich sind
sie jetzt gar nicht so weit von habck
weg weil habck sagt ja auch in einer
Welt wo alle subventionieren wie der
Teufel genau können wir jetzt sozusagen
nicht katholisch tun da müssen wir auch
fün gerade sein lassen und müssen auch
heftig subventionieren für dagegen
anubventionieren nein also
subventionieren ist was anderses
investieren also eine subvenstion da bin
ja dafür aber Investition sch mal der
Bund hat ja trotz dieser Schuldenlast
die wir jetzt gemacht haben kürz be von
Forschung und Entwicklung das muss man
vorstellen ja der Bund hat jetzt sich
entschieden z.B die zwei großen
Chipfabriken zu machen kürz da für
andere Mittel in der wirtschaftsf das
ist Subvention also wenn man sagt SK
baut für 2 Milliarden und 10 Milliarden
Kri versprochen W ein schwerer
Rückschlag wir hatten Intel auch bei uns
wir haben keine sowas anbieten können
wir hatten noch nicht den Platz
ehlichesag für Intel und ich finde es
für Sachsen Anhalt und auch die anderen
Entscheidung für Sachsen gut und helfen
das ser aber dann muss der Bund auch
nicht nur sagen ich ma 15 Milliarden für
zwei Chipfabriken Kürze deragegen z.B
die Förderung der E-Mobilität wir hatten
im letzten jah die IAA oder diesem die
IAA und das sieht schon echt komisch aus
wenn Du siehst wie die Chinesen ihre
Autos massiv fördern wir kürzen das und
beschweren uns dass die Chinesen den
europäischen Markt aufbauen also ich
finde so Industrien von außerhalb poolen
gut kann man alles machen aber muss auch
ein Wettbewerbsprogramm für die
heimische machen z.B hätte man für
vieles von dem Geld auch
Unternehmenssteuern massiv gesenkt
wäde Deutschland wesentlich
wettbewerbsfähiger und das machen ir die
Amerikaner sehr clever aber wie würden
sie es machen wenn sie prinzipiell bei
habck sind dass der Staat diese
Investition bin Prinzip be hab so wie
der
habchuldigung nur ich rede auch nicht
lange also wenn sie prinzipiell be habbe
sind dass der Staat Investitionen auch
unterstützen muss wenn es in die
Zukunftstechnologien geht woher soll der
das Geld nehmen weil er sagt ja das ist
im Rahmen unserer Haushalte nicht zu
bewältigen und dafür kann man auch nicht
die Schuldenbremse aussetzen weil ja
keine Notlage das ist ja sozusagen so
und dann müssten sie schon die Frage
beantworten also wenn sie seine
Investitionen im Kern richtig finden
dann müssen Sie auch ein
Finanzierungskonzept vorlegen erstens
finde ich die Fixierung die habbeck hat
beim Teil der Investitionen die falschen
Prioritäten zweitens gibt die
Bundesregierung enorm viel Geld aus also
noch mal Beispiel das Bürgergeld
empfinde ich persönlich aber auch
politisch als einen schweren Fehler
nicht nur die Steigerung sondern das
ganze Anreiz sie wür kürzen ja massiv
anders aufstellen W machen ja zum einem
Mal
äh diese Verbindung Flucht also mit
Flucht der Zugang zum Bürgergeld für
jemand der neu nach Deutschland kommt
ist falsch der müsste für die Zukunft
geändert werden es ist auch von den
andreitsystemen falsch es muss generell
weniger sein es muss mehr Anreize zum
Arbeiten geben es muss mehr Sanktionen
geben im Moment ist es so in Deutschland
dass wir auch auf Dauer was die
Zuwanderung betrifft glaube ich wenig
motivierte Arbeitskräfte bekommen wenn
man die Alternative hat Bürgergeld zu
bekommen das mit vielen Lohngruppen
vergleichbar ist übrigens kein Vorwurf
gegen Menschen die das Nutzen Vorwurf an
den Staat der ein solches System macht
mit viel weniger Bürgergeld mit einem
anderen heizgesetz und wesentlich
weniger kosten ermittelst du viel Geld
dafür um Technologien zu also sie würden
das was der Staat aufstellen soll für
diese neuen Technologien aus dem
laufenden
Haushalt machen wir in Bayern wir haben
uns nenn sie doch mal eine Hausnummer
für den bundesal ja du könntest ja mit
Dench Technologien mit 5 6 7 Milliarden
dazu hast du einen riesen Schub du musst
D eine 30 40 50 Milliarden machen so und
wenn sie nämlich mal anschauen auch in
dem in dem vor sind sehr viele Maßnahmen
drin die gar nichts mit Hightech zu tun
haben dasind einzelförderen von Wind und
anderen erneuerbaren Energien drin die
nicht annähend Hightech sind das ist
vorhanden z.B diese großen Projekte für
grünen Stahl glaub sind eins in Duisburg
eins in im Saarland und zwei andere die
Kosten richtig viel Geld ist das richtig
oder ist das falsch das sind Projekte
die kann man machen dann muss man aber
halt wo anders in dem Haushalt kürzen
und würden Sie für den grünenstahl im
Haushalt kürzen ja wir müssen ja sowieso
kürzen in dem ganzen Haushalt ich bin
jetzt kein Haushälter
bin Finanzpolitiker Finanzminister
gewesen W ich immer schuldenfreie
Haushalte ich wei wo würden sie noch
kürzen da sogar wo würden sie re also
ich hab jetzt schon also das bürgeld
würden sie reangengesetz sind 18 glaub
fast 19 Milliarden das Bürgergeld sind
sind um die 6 Milliarden äh ähm bei der
kindergsicherung der ganze
bürokratieauwand deutlich reduzieren das
kannst du deutlich reduzieren von dem
Geld das jetzt ist kannst du deutlich
reduziereniv reduzieren von sechs auf
wie viel wür die Hälfte wecken ich will
es n einmal verstehen das das das muss
ich das muss dann durch das jeige
Verfahren gewährleistet werden dann
durch den extremen Hoh Zugang der
Migration durch die Herausforderung der
Migration da werden wir noch drüber
reden entstehen immense Kosten für unser
Land im sozialen aber auch in der
Aufwendung der Kommunen das ganze
Konzept ist sol drund die gehen ja sogar
her und hab gestrichen
ma ganz kurz wie spart man bei Migration
würde ich einmal gerne verstehen die
Zuwanderung reduzieren wie wie machen
sie das W wir das Thema als groß auf
also Zurückweisung an der Grenze
zurückweise und der Grenze durch
Grenzschutz durch meiner mein nach eine
überdenkung des Artikel des
asylgrundrechtes nämlich das
asylgrundrecht ist für die jetzige
Situation nicht geschaffen können es von
der Herausforderung nicht bewältigen
plus auch dem Recht in Europa so wie es
die Dänen haben Zurückweisung zu machen
pullfaktoren zu
reduzieren und und und damit würden wir
die Zuwanderung bergänzen übrigens auch
Abkommen mit der Türkei zu machen und
sichere herkunftsten also das ganze
große Paket das jetzt so langsam sich
bewegt aber das auf keinen Fall
ausreicht weil deutschland braucht eine
Integrationsgrenze Bundespräsident sagt
Belastungsgrenze ich glaube wir brauchen
eine Integrationsgrenze wir werden es
sonst nicht vernünftig organisieren
können in Integration und das sind alles
riesenbaustellen dieg okay machen wir
gleich Alexander sie wollten gerade nur
dass keiner schimpft dass ich nicht
Fakten gescheckt habe also Bürgergeld da
habe ich z kritische Leitartikel gegen
geschrieben aber selbst wenn man es
abwickelt kommt man ja nicht runter
unter das Existenzminimum so und auch
Gerichte kommen und sagen und
Kindergrundsicherung bin ich in der
Kritik bei ihnen aber wird
haushaltswirksam erst 2025 also ist
nichts von dem wo wir jetzt reden also
das ich möchte sie gar nicht jetzt jetzt
grillen aber das ist der
Grundwiderspruch der Position der Union
ja also die Union die völlig Recht hatte
die Konstruktion der Ampel zu
kritisieren ja muss aber natürlich
irgendwann wenn sie gefragt wird wollt
es ihr machen müssen sie sagen so und
dann gibt es eine Position wie sie z.B
die Wirtschaftsweise grim vertrat
gestern in dieser Sendung die ist
ordnungspolitisch total sauber finde ich
persönlich total richtig die sagt lass
es den Marktregeln über Preise
Ordnungspolitik gar nicht mehr
subventionieren ganz sauber wir will
noch mal ganz kurz erklären weil es für
die die es nicht gesehen haben im Grunde
sagt Subventionen eigentlich
weitestgehend weg und auf meine
Nachfrage ob wir dann in Kauf nehmen
dass bestimmte energieintensive
Unternehmen beispielsweise wie die dann
verlieren sagt sie ja dann wird das so
sein ja Abschieden von bestimmten
Branchen sag wie Herr Söder die ganze
subventioniererei für die Heizung das
ist alles teurer Quatsch das soll
sousagen der CO2 Preis Regeln genau kann
man so machen und mancher aus der CDU
vor allen Dingen im Bundestag klingt
auch so nur ob die Union wenn sie
regiert dafür die politische Kraft hat
das will ich erstmal sehen weil dann
muss die Union ja sagen hey deine
Gasrechnung wird teurer und das kriegst
du jetzt nicht subveniert weil du
hättest ja eine wermepumpe einbauen
können und und und also
schönes Konzept aber da bin ich mal
gespannt ob die Union das dann in aller
Härte durchzieht darf ich noch pa
zurückkommen also deswegen ist ja auch
kein im triumfg weil jeder sieht die
schwere Herausforderung m aber noch mal
zurück wenn wir jetzt näich dran denken
also ich würde jetzt nicht hergehen und
sagen me energieintensive Unternehmen
sind egal mm darum kommt der Punkt dass
die Energiepolitik in Deutschland nicht
stimmt weil die Preise auch so hoch sind
weil wir keine eigene wie früher
Stromerzeugung in größerem Ausmaß machen
es fehlt eine wirkliche
energieperspektive der Zeugen im eigenen
Land noch einmal ich empfinde das als
unehrlich und Selbstbetrug woanders
Energieformen anzunehmen und selbst im
eigenen Land zagen wir wollen haben das
funktioniert bevor wir gleich zum Mega
Thema Migration kommen würde ich gerne
noch Robin Alexander fragen wie haben
sie dann den Auftritt und die Spitze von
Robert habck gegen den Bundeskanzler
empfunden wie haben sie das wahrgenommen
vielleicht schauen wir uns die die
Sequenz noch einmal ganz kurz
angemeinsam darum
ging's ist es zutreffend dass es die FDP
war die darauf bestanden hat diese
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und dass wir
deshalb jetzt unter anderem in der
Situation sind in der wir sind die
Regierung hat im Jahr 23 die
Schuldenbremse nein die den Notfall
nicht ausgerufen gehabt und das ist eine
gemeinsame Entscheidung der Regierung
gewesen hinter der sie vollumfänglich
stand Definition entscheidet per
Definition entscheidet eine Regierung
immer gemeinsam eine Entscheidung hinter
der sie keine eine Regierung mehr hinter
der sie gestanden
haben ich will jetzt nicht den
Bundeskanzler zitieren aber ich kann
mich nicht mehr daran
erinnern ja wir finden das witzig aber
Olaf Scholz findet das nicht witzig ich
auch gefragt ja er wird diese
kumexaffäre nicht los und das hängt an
ihm und der letzte Vizekanzler der hier
Witze damals über eine Kanzlerin gemacht
hat hieß Philip Rösler und hatte Angela
Merkel mit einem Frosch verglichen und
das ist der FDP auch nicht gut bekommen
aber noch mal sachlich stimmt das ist
doch hier ja me meine Frage war haben
sie haben sie gerade haben sie gerade
Angela Merkel mit einem Frosch
verglichen aber aber noch mal um das um
um um das den Leuten zu erklären weil da
ist ja wirklich da da sitzt sozusagen
der der Frosch im Brunnen klar wollten
die Grünen das nicht so die Grünen
wollten diese ganzen Investitionen
finanzieren aus einer Mischung aus
Steuererhöhung und Verschuldung das kann
man ablehnen aber sie haben es vorher
gesagt und die SPD hätte es mitgemacht
und auch schön Sozialleistung drauf
gelegt und Lindner hat gesagt ihr könnt
machen was ihr wollt aber keine
Steuerung und keine Verschuldung und da
hätte ein Weg gefunden werden müssen und
der Weg ist nicht gefunden worden
sondern olaf schz hat gesagt guck mal
als Finanzminister habe ich schon was
vorbereitet und das war dieser KTF und
das ist auch das Problem weil was 60
Milliarden ja woran jetzt alles hängt
das ist also man kann jetzt sagen es ist
ein Trick der aufgeflogen ist aber es
ist eigentlich versäumt worden eine
politische Entscheidung zu treffen
nämlich welche Klimapolitik machen wir
und wie bezahlen wir das so aber da das
verweigert wurde muss die nächste
Regierung das auch wieder machen also
wenn jetzt die Union und die SPD
übernehmen oder die Union und die Grünen
oder wer immer der muss trotzdem noch
mal besprechen was machen wir den jetzt
und da sind eigentlich zwei Jahre
verloren gegangen und das ist jenseits
von Ampel hin Ampel her ist das ganz
schön bitter also das ist nicht gut
gelaufen